And considering taking the oxyplush colon cleanser, which is supposed to have an oxygen-based
cleanse on a here's some ingredients, okay, so I could go on half our story about this
but I'll agree via it. There is a NASA scientist who invented the magnesium oxygen combination
to give a oxygen in the intestine tract. He was paid by a group of a supplement company to produce
this as a supplement, right, and this company gave him a percentage of money down and simplified
the story as much as I can here and they were going to pay him the rest after they got the complete
formulation. We left out a piece of the formulation because this supplement company kind of cheated him.
So all the magnesium oxygen products on the market actually don't work like the research shows
it will work. I don't need to be a stickler but they are stealing the research that he used from NASA
and claiming that that is valid in their product but actually there's something that he left out
of the product so it doesn't actually work. Well this scientist was actually then developed a
relationship with the order of the parent company of US enzymes. The parent company of US enzymes
who makes a lot of enzymes for a lot of the supplement companies out there developed a relationship
with this guy and the guy who owns the parent company of US enzymes. I know him. He's one of those
overachievers. He's climbed every of the highest mountains. There's a term for somebody who's climbed
all the peaks mountains. He's this overachiever single guy at 40 something and he's made himself
a become a probably a billionaire but he just is a super anal person who wants to do everything
right. It isn't really concerned about money. Well he developed a relationship with this NASA scientist
to develop this oxygenation of magnesium that can help kill stuff in your gut. Well in that
relationship this guy, the guy who's the owner of the US enzyme, his first name is Troy. I'll
create the machine that can do this for you and we'll go have some and I don't need the money.
Well US enzymes produced the product. I actually went and visited that US enzymes parent company
and Troy gave the end-dust in about six other doctors a tour while they're finishing this machine.
We got to actually see the machine. Well the product that they have produced and they still don't even
market it. Long story short, don't take that product. Take this one. It's called Cleans
design. That's how you're spelling. Cleansine by US enzyme. So we have it in our store.
This is the product you should take. It's far superior product. It's actually made by the NASA
Harvard scientist who developed a technology and got all the patents and then all the other companies
are not using the right formulation and it really it's not an expensive product and it's that is how
you get oxygen to the oxygen-based tissue to the colon. Oxygen-based magnesium to the colon.
So use that product by US enzyme. Anybody can take it. It doesn't hurt anybody.
There's not necessarily necessary for everybody but anybody can take that.